il existe une vraie différence entre
l'usb-c quoi pouvoir retrouver dans
l'iPhone 15 et l'USB c'est qu'on pourra
retrouver dans les iPhone 15 pro au-delà
de toutes les annonces qu'a fait Apple
avec une nouvelle puce avec une
amélioration de la photo avec un titane
qui arrive sur la gamme pro c'est pour
moi une nouveauté qui est essentielle
est extrêmement importante parce qu'elle
implique d'utiliser de nouveaux câbles
pour venir recharger ses iPhone mais
également faire du transfert de données
directement depuis votre iPhone vers
votre Mac parce que vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que l'Union européenne impose aux
fabricant qu'à partir du 28 décembre
2024 tous les smartphones qui seront
fabriqués devront avoir un port USB C
pour pouvoir être vendu en Europe
l'Europe reste un très gros marché et
notamment pour Apple qui devait donc
faire quelque chose ils l'ont fait une
année en avance en décidant d'intégrer
des sept années les prises usb-c on va
donc regarder ce que ça change
concrètement et combien ça va vous
coûter
en couleur et vous avez la modélix qui
permet d'avoir un verseau
interchangeable et donc personnalisable
selon les envies du moment les produits
de rhinoshi sont bien évidemment
compatibles maxife avec un design unique
et des possibilités de personnalisation
infinies et des milliers design qui sont
faits avec des collaborations
prestigieuses One Piece Naruto Marvel
Dragon Ball NBA il a NASA il y en a
énormément mais vous pouvez en plus de
ça venir imprimer directement vos photos
sur votre protection et il est
maintenant possible d'utiliser des
images sur des fonds transparentes
Merino aussi fabrique bien plus que des
coques ils ont également des protections
d'écran antichoc avec une toute nouvelle
version anti lumière bleue mais
également les protections classiques la
transparente la mate et l'anti espion ou
en verre trempé ils ont également des
protections pour les objectifs photos
mais aussi des câbles de recharge
Lightning vers USBA Lightning vers usb-c
usb-c et bien plus encore mais ils ont
également des lanières pour téléphone
des dragons bref rhinoshi propose
énormément de produits pour venir
protéger ici vos iPhone 15 et n'oubliez
pas vous profitez de moins 10% pendant
48 heures je vous mets le lien juste en
bas dans la description et en plus de ça
économiser jusqu'à 26 euros avec le
combo coque protection d'écran et
objectif photo mais avant toute chose
savez-vous ce qui est un câble usb-c
enfin savez-vous réellement on comprend
effectivement effectivement la question
de la connectique parce que quand on
pense usb-c on pense avant tout
connectique on vient l'opposer très
souvent au Lightning qui est le port
propriétaire d'Apple en tout cas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui même s'il reste il est voué
à disparaître mais l'usb-c c'est bien
plus qu'une connectique puisque même si
vous avez de la connectique de part et
d'autre de votre câble vous avez au
milieu ce câble qui va venir faire
transiter de l'information mais pas
uniquement de la formation on aura bien
évidemment de la donner ça va être des
photos des vidéos toutes les
informations qui vont venir transiter
par votre câble et s'il y a deux normes
à distinguer au niveau des iPhone 15 si
vous allez sur le site d'Apple vous
allez voir que les choses sont écrites
façon assez clair mais il faut quand
même venir les chercher vous allez sur
votre page de l'iPhone vous allez dans
les caractéristiques et là on va tout en
bas au niveau de recharge et extension
et là vous le voyez ça écrit clairement
USB 2 avec un débit qui va jusqu'à 480
mégabits par seconde ce qui est tout
simplement aujourd'hui le débit maximal
qu'on peut retrouver sur les câbles
Lightning d'Apple donc il n'y a aucune
différence entre la vitesse maximale de
transfert de données qu'on peut avoir
avec les câbles Lightning qu'on a
actuellement versus les câbles en USB
c'est que vous allez avoir avec vos
iPhone 15 et 15 plus et l'autre point
qui est intéressant va venir descendre
un petit peu pour regarder et qui vous
le marque bien que votre câble de charge
en USB C21 mètres est inclus ici on
regarde bien ici on vient zoom un peu
dans l'image on voit qu'on a ce côté
très C au niveau du câble ça je sais pas
vous mais moi ça me fait vraiment penser
au câble qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui au
niveau des iPads bien évidemment
toujours en usbc mais là où la
différence se fait réellement il vaut
des iPhone 15 pro qui soit dit en
passant en design qui a l'air d'être
superbement incroyable et bien vous
descendez tout en bas de la même manière
et là vous voyez toujours au niveau de
recharge extension que là vous êtes en
USB3 avec un débit qui va jusqu'à 10
Gigabits par seconde c'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus avec merci Apple un câble
de recharge qui est toujours inclus mais
ce cas permet également de faire
transiter de l'énergie pour venir
recharger votre smartphone alors là il y
a un truc qui est super intéressant
regard distinguer par rapport à ce qu'on
compare aujourd'hui sur Android parce
que on se dit qu'en ayant une prise en
usbc on peut venir utiliser son chargeur
Android sur un iPhone c'est justement
l'idée ici de l'Union européenne de se
dire on a tous plein de câbles de
recherche de tous les côtés c'est pas
forcément bon pour la planète ça coûte
en plus de l'argent on va l'utiliser un
voire deux max à la maison raison mais
dans les faits ça va pas être aussi
simple pourquoi parce qu'il y a
plusieurs normes à venir distinguer ici
on a déjà l'USB pour delivery on a la
Qualcomm quickcharge on a celle des
fabricants aussi dash charge la marque
charge et tous ces chargeurs sont pas
forcément compatibles entre eux parce
que il y a aussi un truc à dire
distinguer ici qu'est-ce qu'un chargeur
alors on sait tous ce qu'un chargeur
vous avez des chargeurs j'ai des
chargeurs on a tous des chargeurs mais
en fait un chargeur est constitué d'un
câble usb-c il a été mis et compagnie et
d'un bloc de charge il y a un autre truc
à savoir qui est super intéressant c'est
qu'en fait la plupart du temps le câble
du chargeur va communiquer avec le
smartphone et ils vont se reconnaître si
jamais le câble est différent de la
marque du smartphone et bien ils vont
pas se reconnaître et la qualité de la
charge sera dégradée bien que ce que
propose l'Union européenne est
totalement louable ici dans les faits
voyez c'est pas aussi simple parce que
ça reste d'ailleurs un business pour les
marques qui préférons toujours vous
vendre leur chargeur donc utiliser le
chargeur d'une marque concurrente alors
après soit il est rassuré il existe des
chargeurs multimarques qu'on peut venir
acheter et qui feront très bien
l'affaire il y a un autre point qui est
super intéressant apple a présenté sa
nouvelle puce à 17 pro d'ailleurs sur
les temps passant c'est intéressant
c'est la première fois qu'il va utiliser
sur les iPhone la dénomination pro sur
une puce et d'année on avait la puce à
16 bionique là on a la puce à 17 pro
est-ce que ça veut dire que sur les
iPhone 16 l'année prochaine 16 et 16 +
on aurait une puce à 17 non pro et que
là on a une puce pro sur les modèles pro
allez savoir justement cette puce à 17
pro et bien elle a un contrôleur USB qui
permet d'avoir de l'USB 3 ce qu'on
retrouve fatalement pas sur les iPhone
15 et 15 plus qui ont la puce à 16
bionique de l'année dernière avec cette
nouvelle puce à 17 pro on aura donc des
débits qui seront beaucoup plus
importants avec de l'USB3 versus le USB
2 et c'est là où c'est super intéressant
parce que quand on va chercher un peu
plus loin sur le site d'Apple vous allez
voir que le câble de recherche qui
inclut avec votre iPhone 15 pro et bien
c'est pas du tout un câble en USB 3 non
c'est de l'USB 2 pour ça il faut aller
fouiller dans les accessoires on va
remonter au niveau des iPhone et là on
vient chercher au niveau des accessoires
et là on descend légèrement et oh
alimentation et câbles comme par magie
apparaît je vois qu'ici j'ai un nouveau
câble de recharge en USB C 240 watts de
mètres ok alors si je l'ai regardé ce
fameux cap de 240 watts de mètres et
bien en descendant je verrai que c'est
de l'USB 2 et pas de l'USB3 et que si je
passe sur la longueur de 1 m je passe de
240 watts à 60 watts qui est sur du
temps passant toujours en USB 2 si je
veux de l'USB 3 je dois aller chercher
encore un peu plus loin tiens magnifique
je vois arriver un nouveau câble
thunderbol 4 USB C pro de 1 m 79 euros
et qui lui par contre et bien en USB 3
jusqu'à 10 Gigabits par seconde et après
thunderbol 4 USB 4 40 Gigabits par
seconde mais la se concerne absolument
pas votre iPhone puisque l'iPhone 15 pro
n'est pas en capacité de gérer l'USB 4
et ici quel que soit la longueur on aura
exactement le même câble ça changera
globalement pas grand chose ici si ce
n'est bien évidemment le prix puisque le
câble de 3 mètres fait 179 euros et le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que ce
câble là vous voyez il est noir il est
tout noir et si vous retournez sur la
fiche produit de votre iPhone 15 Pro
vous voyez que le câble qui est fourni
il est tout blanc c'est donc un câble en
USB 2 et non pas en USB 3 bien que votre
iPhone de 15 pro soit capable de gérer
de l'USB3 et bien le cas le fournit par
Apple n'est pas en USB3 mais en USB 2
alors je me suis posé la question je me
suis dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'Apple
vous annonce avoir de l'USB3 on peut
titre dans les specs et qu'en réalité il
ne propose pas de câble en USB3 et bien
tout simplement comme ils viennent
segmenter les gammes le câble en USB 3
qui coûte cher et vraiment dédié à
l'usage des professionnels qui ont
besoin de tout transfert beaucoup plus
rapide on se parle ici uniquement de
besoin de taux transfert puisque de
toute façon on ne peut pas venir
recharger un iPhone à une vitesse de 100
watts soyons clairs ça va être du 20W ou
du 30 watts et pour s'en rendre compte
on va fouiller une fois de plus dans les
accessoires chez Apple l'adaptateur
secteur le bloc de charge le plus
puissant que je peux venir retrouver
c'est de l'usb-c 30 watts bien
évidemment je vous montre usb-c derrière
ils vous disent qu'il vous recommande de
l'utiliser avec un MacBook Air mais vous
pouvez également l'utiliser avec
certains modèles d'iPhone ou d'iPad pro
on se parle donc ici d'iPhone 15 pro et
d'iPad pro après ce que je ne sais pas
c'est si dans tous les cas même on
l'utilisant en usb-c 30 watts vous allez
être limité à 20 watts de toute façon le
bloc de charge qui était inclus avec un
iPhone parce qu'au moment où il les ont
plus mis et bien c'était uniquement du
20 watts dès celui-ci qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui à 25 euros qui vous permet
de le recharger de 0 à 50% en 30 minutes
environ donc Apple a strictement aucun
intérêt à venir vous mettre un câble en
USB 3 qui viendrait augmenter la note de
votre iPhone si vous êtes un
professionnel et que vous avez besoin de
vitesse de transfert très élevé en USB 3
et bien vous allez venir acheter votre
câble à côté ça ne sert à rien
d'augmenter la note directement on vous
met un câble en USB 2 qui ira très bien
et qui fera de toute façon exactement la
même chose que faisait votre câble en
Lightning avant pas plus pas moins et
l'autre truc qui est intéressant
également à voir ici c'est qu'Apple n'a
pas du tout augmenté ses tarifs par
rapport à ce qu'il y avait l'année
dernière donc ça ne servait à rien de
venir vous mettre un câble qui va
rajouter 179 euros peut-être 100 balles
79 euros en tout cas juste pour pouvoir
faire du transfert jusqu'en 10 Gigabits
par seconde de votre iPhone 15 pro à
votre MacBook le fait qu'Apple soit
obligé de venir mettre de l'usb-c ça
leur donne une opportunité pour venir
segmenter toujours plus les gammes et de
rajouter de la vente additionnelle au
travers des accessoires plus cette
fois-ci destiné au pro et un mon pro il
y a strictement aucun intérêt pour le
particulier de venir acheter un câble en
USB3 aucun le câble fournit avec votre
iPhone suffira largement j'en profite
parce qu'à notre accessoire qui est
arrivé chez Apple et qui raconte cette
histoire de transition qui est vraiment
intéressante c'est la data usb-c vers
Lightning à 35 €. vous vous branchez
directement en Lightning vous ressortez
de l'autre côté en USB C donc si vous
avez encore besoin de venir utiliser
votre câble Lightning mais de côté vous
vous branchez en USB C et bien vous
allez pouvoir le faire grâce à cet
accessoire à 35 euros alors le seul truc
qui ne change pas cette année c'était
pouvoir venir recharger votre smartphone
avec Max safe et qui d'ailleurs maxaf
même si on en a pas trop parlé cette
année reste très probablement l'avenir
de la recharge exclusive au niveau des
iPhone puisque à terme l'usb-c lui aussi
sera voie disparaître comme son petit
copain Lightning et on se retrouvera
avec des iPhones qui se chargeront
uniquement en maxife et où transfert de
données se fera au travers du wifi
d'ailleurs on voit cette année au niveau
de la gamme Pro que enfin Apple a mis du
wifi 6e dans ses iPhones pas les iPhone
15 et iPhone 15 plus mais bien au niveau
des modèles pro ils viennent donc dans
un premier temps combler un retard et
dans un deuxième temps entre ouvrir la
porte vers de la recharge 100% sans fil
sur les iPhones mais ça c'est encore une
toute autre histoire dont on parlera
probablement l'année prochaine si c'est
dans deux ans et d'ailleurs si vous
cherchez les meilleurs accessoires pour
venir utiliser avec votre smartphone et
bien vous en ai fait une vidéo elle est
juste là allez je tenais vous allez voir
il y a des choses extrêmement
surprenantes